you know what makes a great speedster
it's being the light than the
greengrocer I lost my speed I think I
found it
[Music]
Ares is a speedster now I'll take it
from here it's my turn to do what you've
been doing
monitor from here then I'm honored no
it's super annoying Terrell the hell are
you doing please give me my powers back
you Louis can you hear me okay
[Music]
was he okay I'm more than okay
I'm super
everybody it's Charlie so if you guys
didn't remember they did the exact same
thing on Smallville where Louis got
Clark's powers for like a single episode
the reason why she got powers was a
little bit different the flash is just
doing their spin on that so I'll try to
explain the comic book Easter eggs
because there have been a lot of female
speedsters on the flash some of them
super deep cuts that the TV show is
probably never gonna get to and I will
explain the purple lightning because I
know that's a big question speedster
lightning color is actually a pretty big
deal in the comics so if you're finding
me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos there's
a new round of the flash ring giveaway -
all you have to do to enter just be a
subscriber and leave a flash related
comment on the video so if you have
absolutely no idea what's going on why
is iris West a speedster in this episode
they get their DNA swapped by a bus meta
while they're out on the town so iris
gets the powers of the flash then a
couple separate problems come up they
can only be solved by someone with
Barry's powers so Barry just has to talk
iris through it then they just have a
couple of those funny moments like they
have on Smallville where Clark stands
there and Lois just runs away in the
middle of the conversation Barry's like
oh that's kind of rude they did the same
thing during Justice League
Louis I love you Louis
I don't think you ought to do what he
did so you can get the main reason why I
think that her lightning is purple is
just because they want it to look
different not because it has anything to
do with how fast she is there are a lot
of you that we're asking me does this
have anything to do with the tornado
twins because in the recent rebirth
comics both the tornado twins have
purple lightning so it's like wait a
minute maybe they're trying to tease
something down the road we're gonna need
more diapers it's totally possible that
they're trying to do something like that
but the number one reason really is just
to make it look different like they gave
her the excess costume from the comics
like it doesn't have the lightning bolt
down the middle maybe they'll do a
version of this later but obviously
berry gets his powers back by the end of
the episode and I don't think that we're
gonna see iris West becoming a speedster
ever again in the future I think that
she's just meant to be a one-time thing
because the whole basis for the iris
character is that she's the lightning
rod that grounds Barry The Living God
who spends all of his time doing all
these crazy superhero things she's
supposed to be the one thing that makes
him normal which means that she has to
be normal meaning that she doesn't have
powers but getting to the Smallville of
it all if you didn't watch that TV show
or you don't know what was going on with
Lois Lane getting the powers of Superman
they're been at least 10 times in the
comics that Lois Lane has gotten powers
on the Smallville TV show it was them
getting ready to get married it is sort
of like a marriage counseling session
jor-el didn't want them to get married
because they weren't equals and he felt
like Lois wouldn't understand what it
was like to be with someone like
Superman who needed to protect the
entire world like being married to the
greatest hero the world has ever known
is a very different thing than being
married to a normal person so it was a
way to make her understand how important
Superman was to the world jor-el gave
her his powers for a day so that she
could experience that and obviously they
had a lot of fun with it
there's a lot of Lois SuperSpeed moments
during the episode but obviously
Superman's SuperSpeed looks different
than the Flash's SuperSpeed because he
doesn't give off lightning good
old-fashioned super
[Music]
maybe was your Ottoman to teach us a
little something about patience well if
he did then you're about to feel I'm
driving
the comic book panel that everybody
photoshopped a long time ago with iris
West face on this new 52 Irish West
costume is actually from flash vol 4
number 22 in the reason why she was
wearing this costume is is because Barry
was protecting her from a mystery
speedforce killer that turned out to be
her brother so turns out she wasn't in
any danger that ended up being the
Daniel West reverse flash and in the
comics they didn't know each other that
well like they weren't married or
anything like that
she just admired and reported about the
flash every once in a while so he gave
her this special costume to cloak her
signature from the Speed Force killer so
I'm assuming because Barry and iris had
that conversation at last week's episode
about how they never spend any regular
people time together just doing normal
stuff they might be in the middle of
something like that when this new
mystery bus medic comes along and swaps
their powers the real thing to think
about though is that how does this fit
into des Vosges plan because like last
week's episode Barry opening that second
portal to the Speed Force allowing all
that lightning out that was part of
Davos plan meaning that even if this
seems like a really silly premise for an
episode their powers get swapped for a
week then how does that also help two
foes ultimate goal in what four
dimensional chess are the writers
playing like what else are they trying
to tease because there's usually a
couple of different things that happen
during flash episodes they have like
some funny cool adventure but within
that they also tee up some bigger idea
that they pay off later
like the whole flash time thing back
during episode 10 how am I in here what
is this then several weeks later it
becomes the basis for an entire episode
so iris West getting SuperSpeed for like
a brief episode just having a little bit
of fun also will probably tee up some
bigger concept that they'll pay off in a
couple weeks but I think a lot of us are
all wondering if this has something to
do with her maybe having children
eventually getting pregnant there's a
lot of things that have to happen before
that happens like she definitely doesn't
look pregnant right now but in the
comics right after the thinker arc was
over they discovered that they were
pregnant with twins now it was the wally
west era but twins just run in the flash
family so wally and linda had twins
Barry and iris had twins
there's Cecile's baby there's just like
a lot of babies on the flash in general
there's coffee shop girl from the future
that seems like she might actually hate
all the members on Team flash which just
as new wrinkles to the equation but
hopefully that explains a little bit
about what's going on with this iris
west episode so I think you know for the
most part they just wanted to have some
fun with iris getting powers for a week
and then use that as part of this larger
think or Ark and use it to tee up some
bigger concepts so for the most part I
don't think that they're gonna go back
to this and yeah though I mean they
might have like a we are the flash
moment but again I think that will
ultimately be paid off when Barry
himself like his body gets taken by the
thinker because remembers the thinker's
body is degenerating at an exponential
rate the more powers that he absorbs so
that means that even after he eventually
probably takes Ralph's powers and is
able to sort of fix that a little bit
he'll still need another meta that can
heal themselves at an exponential rate
which is Barry as the flash so again
when it comes to twist like this twist
like we are the flash just play the long
game remember this is four dimensional
chess we're playing so it's all stuff
that they'll wrap up in the finale which
is still several weeks away but I do
love the idea of the samuel l.jackson
explainer for purple lightning like
because it looks cool like I want a
purple lightsaber because I can't tell
myself apart from the other people on
screen I just wanted to look different
okay Sam Jackson wants a purple
lightsaber purple lightsabers suddenly
exist in the Star Wars universe I was
like well [ __ ] I want to be able to find
myself then there's big old things I
said to George
you think maybe I can get a purple
lightsaber might save the green or light
sabers Iridum yeah but I want a purple
one I'm like the second baddest Jedi in
the universe let me think about it
and I came back to reshoot you said show
you something already called a shitstorm
online so there's never any question
about it yes they do play it fast and
loose with lightning color on the flash
like the purple lightning should be
faster than red lightning technically
like reverse flash should be one of the
fastest people sabotage white lightning
should ultimately be the very fastest
but they mix and match a lot of things
so I don't think they're always super
consistent when it comes to stuff like
that Jesse quick really was the first
real female speedster who got powers and
kept them patty spivot
technically the very first female
speedster she was called Miss Flash but
it was sort of like a mine space thing
where the flash was imagining what it
would be like if she got powers so that
was kind of super ridiculous that was
back to in the 1970s on us the giveaway
winner when I post new DC there's some
cool new Whicher there's some cool new
Marvel stuff that I'll try to pose a
bunch of trailers just dropped so just
check that top pin comment of mine for
what videos are coming next but leave
all your requests in the comments so
click here for my flash video and click
here for brand new infinity war thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight